the high court's ruling on roe up ends
nearly 50 years of legal precedent now
that raises a lot of legal questions
constitutional scholar jeffrey rosen
joins us now to help us sort this out he
is president and ceo of the nonpartisan
national constitution center good
morning jeffrey it's really good to have
you here on this morning in particular
you know the polling shows that the
majority of americans did not want roe v
wade overturned so why does it why is
the supreme court seemingly so out of
step with the american public
well the majority opinion said that it's
their job to ignore public opinion and
to follow the constitution wherever it
leads the fact that they didn't change
their opinion after it leaked should
suggest that they're determined to hold
the line there and they may be out of
step with america in a way that would be
historically unusual in american
politics
how far in how far now can states go to
enforce these abortion bans
well this is the central question and
the legal the legal issues are going to
be so complicated first can a woman
travel out of state to get an abortion
justice kavanaugh said yes he said that
the right to travel protects your right
to go to a state that is pro-choice but
a bunch of the
anti-choice states are going to be
trying to prosecute doctors out of state
who offer abortions or those who aid and
abet them there are only two precedents
on those it's gonna they'll be tested in
court
the pro-choice states will refuse to
extradite women who cross straight lines
so the bottom line is it's going to be
tied up in the courts for a very long
time and very very complicated state by
state
yeah but you see a lot of companies are
already stepping up saying we will
reimburse women who have to travel out
of state what impact do you think this
will have
well it'll have huge effects on where
people decide to work and a lot is going
to turn on the availability of the
abortion pill which you were talking
about earlier the justice department
last week said that states may not ban
the abortion pill based on disagreement
with its health or safety and generally
federal regulations preempt state
regulations but a bunch of states are
already moving to ban the abortion pill
those will be tested in court and
ultimately it's not clear what the
supreme court will say about this
preemption issue so there once again uh
we're not going to know the final answer
for a long time to come
uh jeffrey justice clarence thomas wrote
in his opinion that the court should
reconsider same-sex marriage and access
to birth control now the majority
opinion also took pains to say we're not
going to do that this is different
but
give us a reality check here
does what clarence thomas wrote
portend other rights being threatened in
this ruling
well as as jan crawford said earlier the
majority said abortion is different than
gay marriage and contraception because
it involves a fetus and there's another
difference between contraception and
abortion namely that there was a
tradition of product protecting
contraception in the 60s and the courts
that there's no tradition of protecting
abortion but the liberal justices were
not convinced there's an amazing line in
the descent where the liberals say the
majority says it's not going to question
same-sex marriage and contraception
scout's honor they basically said you
can't bank on that promise so the the
liberal justices aren't convinced
justice clarence thomas obviously said
that he is willing to reconsider those
laws so once again tremendous legal
uncertainty on the central issues of our
time
wow it affects so many things
politically socially medically it's
still some so much more to discuss here
jeffrey rosen thank you so much for your
time